I'm Dallas Morning News ESPN around the
horn panelists you want to jump into
this conversation in all Tim I just want
to say this while I'm not a Kraftwerk
fan Kraftwerk is apparently important
influence on some earlier Radiohead
albums and Radiohead is the greatest day
of the last 20 years so just want to put
that out there
okay strong statement there buyin is
giving you a standing ovation that you
just said radio had the best band in the
last time who is Radiohead's competition
last 20 years Coldplay wishes it was but
they're not and oh no Chris Martin
admits he goes if it weren't for you two
and Radiohead there'd be no Coldplay yes
he's right Coldplay just announced that
they're working on a new experimental
album and that should be released later
this year and people are just destroying
them like what is it called kid be the
Benz Part two okay so you in your column
and of course you don't write your
headline but the headline says it's too
early for the Cowboys to fire Jason
Garrett but his arrogance is inching him
closer to the end would you say that's a
fair headline for your column well yes
because although you know I wasn't
really expecting the backlash most of
the comment through too early five years
ago too early this season once you've
decided to keep him it I wouldn't fire
him at three and three I mean that or
even well we'll get to it I'm sure but
even after this week now I've written
before after the 2017 season that he
should be fired so I'm not I'm not not
immune to thinking that the Garrett's
should go I just once you're in the
middle of the season usually you don't
accomplish a lot with coaching changes
but I wonder about this Tim where does
this hinge on Lincoln Reilly's
availability of leaving Oklahoma you
know everybody here would like to think
that I've only talked to Linc
Riley once about that and he didn't you
know he's not going to tell me yes I'm
thinking about I'd love to come come to
the Cowboys I just he's got such a thing
going at Oklahoma I don't know I don't
know if you leave that job for the
Dallas Cowboys now you could and if he's
watched a lot and he really believes in
dak Prescott then then he could he could
convince himself that's the way to go
but I mean beyond that there's a huge
drop down to who's next okay but would
you got an extension if your Lincoln
Riley if your Lincoln Riley would you
leave Oklahoma for the Cowboys
no I wouldn't either Lincoln Riley joins
us Thursday I believe is that right Todd
that's correct yeah I wouldn't because I
I'm just not sure what I'm walking into
there but you have to be whoever you
bring in if that's the case they got to
be sold on dak Prescott absolutely and
you also I mean you're starting to see
and it'll take time
we won't know this year starting to see
some decent results from Kliff Kingsbury
in that offense with Kyla Murray and
that would be something like Lincoln
Riley wouldn't bring to the party but
still I mean Oklahoma
I mean Stoops stayed there 17 18 years
Riley's got that thing going obviously
to understate it and he's not getting
fired there any time so I I don't I
don't think I would make a move all
right well what he is the big issue with
the Cowboys they look great against
inferior competition and then they ran
into some good competition and didn't
look good and then they ran into the
Jets and I do we know who the Cowboys
are yet Tim I I do not think we do and
they seem to be a team that while
everybody else deals with injuries if
they have one key guy on either side of
the ball oh my god well Amari Cooper is
not playing well they can't they can't
possibly function on offense anymore
let's let's resort to last year when
they you know couldn't couldn't throw
the ball for seven games till he got
here that's kind of what happened even
though they piled up eventually piled up
some yards Sunday I mean there's no
reason to ever be behind the Jets 21 to
three at the half
and the other side the defense was very
very good last year and they thought
they were going to move up to the elite
class and they've had one good game they
played well against the Saints even
though that was Bridgewater but they did
a good job against chimera and a good
job on Thomas other than that this
defense they don't have any sacks they
don't get turnovers secondaries and
suspect the the highly touted
linebackers aren't doing much so it's
it's really a team that's underachieving
and that's what I think leads everybody
in the direction of the head coach he's
the most popular panelist on around the
horn he also is really a columnist for
the Dallas Morning News
he said Tim Couch on the replay system
it feels like it's broken watching last
night and I I don't want to keep adding
to this I'd like to maybe subtract or
redefine it or something here Tim but if
you had a chance to correct the
officiating in the NFL where would you
start I would do away with replay for
two years I would say for two seasons we
were going back to where we were in the
early 90s Cowboys have to win a couple
Super Bowls last year replay is holding
the Cowboys back know I would do in two
years and obviously there would be an
outcry about the missed call like the
calls and the Lions game it you'd have
to see what is this like and what could
we fix but I mean I think the flow of
the game getting stuff right is a fine
goal but just the delays the length of
time they spend look did that ball move
a little in his hands it seems to be
moving there as he's going to the ground
it's just it's horrible it's not good if
you're watching on TV it's horrible if
you're in the stands sitting there and
you know possibly even in bad weather
waiting for the next play and I thought
for years that that the pass
interference thing needed to be put in
you needed to be able to challenge a 50
yard mistake and as we've seen they
don't care about that rule they're not
going to fix anything till the playoffs
they care about is if we have a bad call
in the playoffs we'll fix it but until
then if you're a Giants receiver going
over the middle and the Patriots safety
just pulls your arm down and clobbers
you we don't we don't really care what
happened last night with the Lions when
it was passed in resort yes they had
that and then they had the two very
suspect calls that it's not a reviewable
thing but you guys the rep the linesman
thought he had his mask and he just had
the collars chest yeah a lot of stuff
went against lines last night how do you
feel about the Cowboys against the
Eagles you know classic battle for first
place Dan - warriors - great teams
you're not getting any point you're not
getting any points on around the horn
for that I'm taking them away from you I
mean it again the Cowboys should be able
to attack the Eagles secondary but they
should have been able to attack the Jets
and beat the Jets and they didn't I you
know I picked the Eagles before the
season they to win the East and the
Cowboys to be a wild-card team I suppose
I would lean toward Philadelphia and
their coach at least trying to fire up
his team saying we're going there to win
and Jason responding with his they're a
great football team we respect them
we'll won't prepare to play the game
just that horrible answer he had hmm are
you on around the horn today I am but
it's a formidable crew dad it's it's
Frank Isola it's Sara Spain and Clinton
Yates one of your favorites if you if
you bring up replay and you if you just
say as I mentioned on Dan Patrick
award-winning show earlier today what
award have you captured lately well I've
been the national national radio host of
the year the Marconi award twice twice
we got that yes I do the reason it was
that like ten years ago that was that
was last year and then a few years prior
to that
[Laughter]
a two-time Emmy nominee for this show
Bayley studio okay way more than a
rather or I'm gonna be rooting for you
tonight I I know you will and I
appreciate it thank you thank you thank
you - that's Italo show Dallas Morning
News and around the horn for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]